[Música]
cuando se descubrió la comida peruana es
una pregunta interesante porque la
comida peruana ha estado siempre con
nosotros la hemos saboreado la hemos
compartido la hemos celebrado desde
siempre desde antes de que se
convirtiera en la celebridad mundial que
hoy es
pero la comida peruana no siempre fue
esta celebridad mundial que pasó cuando
la descubrimos
fue un descubrimiento particular porque
a diferencia por ejemplo del
descubrimiento de reservas de litio en
puno hace unas cuantas semanas
reservas que están bajo tierra que se ha
tenido que explorar para encontrar
nuestra comida ha estado siempre delante
de nosotros
literalmente delante de nuestras narices
entonces qué fue lo que pasó
lo que ocurrió es que un grupo de
peruanos bajo el notable liderazgo de
gastón acurio nos hicieron mirar de
nuevo
nos hicieron revisar nuestras miradas y
descubrir significa literalmente
destapar no nos hicieron destapar la
tierra como para encontrar el litio nos
hicieron cambiar un esquema mental que
teníamos volver a mirar y darnos cuenta
del extraordinario valor de lo que
siempre dábamos por cotidiano nuestra
comida
de alguna manera lo que hicieron fue ser
como un notario que toca nuestra puerta
takata la familia de perú si les traigo
un sobre unos parientes lejanos les han
dejado una extraordinaria herencia su
comida
y qué fue lo que hicimos con nuestra
comida cuando nos supimos herederos de
ella
la volvimos a conocer la red conocimos
la reconocimos en todo su valor y luego
la recreamos jugamos con ella exploramos
sus raíces sus orígenes la fusionamos la
expandimos la enriquecimos convertimos a
la comida peruana en embajadora de
nuestro país en todo el mundo no hay
ciudad importante en este planeta que no
tenga una representación de la comida
peruana convertimos a la comida peruana
en motivo de peregrinación desde el
mundo hacia el perú
convertimos a fin de cuentas a nuestra
comida en el corazón mismo de nuestro
orgullo
pero quizás más interesante todavía que
lo que hicimos con nuestra comida fue
que es lo que hicimos con nosotros
mismos en el proceso porque cuando nos
fuimos acostumbrando a la idea de que
cuando se trata de comida los peruanos
somos jugadores de talla mundial
fuimos derribando barreras mentales a
nuestras posibilidades barreras a
nuestra imaginación de lo que somos
capaces de hacer hoy por hoy los
peruanos cuando se trata de comida no
tenemos límites nos sentimos no sabemos
capaces de absolutamente todo
entonces en el proceso nos transformamos
a nosotros mismos
activamos reservas latentes que son
parte de nuestra identidad los paladares
peruanos no son como cualquier paladar
llevamos generaciones de generaciones
distinguiendo sabores distinguiendo
mixturas y apreciando las derribamos
barreras y activamos todo nuestro
potencial transformando nosotros a
nosotros mismos de una manera que tenía
un impacto increíble quizá el primer
impacto tiene que ver con la autoestima
hoy por hoy los peruanos sentimos un
orgullo a partir de nuestra comida que
no sentíamos antes no solamente lo
sentimos
nos sentimos autorizados a sentirnos
orgullosos si celebran nuestra comida si
la elogian lo entendemos no nos
sorprendemos no nos sonrojamos pero esto
va más allá de un sentimiento individual
en un país como el nuestro que todavía
tiene tantas cosas que nos separan
tantas cosas que nos dividen la comida
ha venido a hacer un espectacular
elemento de unidad de unión entre los
peruanos
acabamos de ver hace poco lo que pasó
con el fútbol a raíz del mundial una
gran unión entre los peruanos pero eso
sucede esporádicamente ojalá más seguido
dentro de poco la comida sin embargo es
un elemento permanente de unión entre
los peruanos un elemento que nos hace
mucha falta
por último pero no por eso menos
importante la comida ha tenido un
poderosísimo impacto económico le ha
cambiado la vida transversalmente a
mucha gente desde pequeños agricultores
medianos agricultores hasta jóvenes que
quieren un trabajo como meseros o que
quieren estudiar para ser cocineros o
jefes de cocina chefs para personas que
quieren poner un restaurante para
hoteleros para escuelas de gastronomía
para arquitectos que diseñan los nuevos
restaurantes para diseñadores que
trabajan en la marca para la propia
industria editorial que publica
bellísimos libros sobre nuestra
gastronomía
tenido tal impacto la comida y nosotros
que hoy por hoy según los world travel
awards que vienen a ser el wall street
journal los los describía como los oscar
del turismo mundial el perú es el mejor
destino culinario del mundo de acuerdo
estos premios no solamente los somos los
somos por seis años consecutivos
cuando hablamos de predominio
futbolístico y pensamos en brasil el
pentacampeón
nosotros somos seis veces campeones
mundiales seis veces consecutivas
tomémonos un instante para procesar
hasta donde hemos llegado
esto por supuesto no sucedió de la noche
a la mañana esto sucedió en el tiempo y
a consecuencia de mucho trabajo de
peruanos trabajando colectivamente
ayudándose en grupo pero a pesar del
extraordinario punto de llegada al que
hemos arribado yo quiero pedirles que le
prestemos atención al punto de partida
cómo comenzó esto
cuando se descubrió la comida peruana
cuando volvimos a mirarnos a nosotros
mismos cuando cambiamos nuestra mirada y
fuimos capaces de reconocer el increíble
valor de esta herencia de todos los
peruanos que es nuestra comida cuando
nos reconocimos en nuestra identidad en
nuestros recursos en lo que somos cuando
buscamos en nuestras fortalezas no en
nuestras carencias
la razón por la que estoy aquí esta
tarde es porque quiero invitarlos a que
volvamos a hacer ese ejercicio
mirémonos de nuevo descubramos esos
recursos a los que nos hemos
acostumbrado y que no estamos valorando
de manera suficiente de alguna forma
quiero ser ese notario que toca la
puerta tac tac tac la familia perú si
les traigo un sobre unos parientes
lejanos les han dejado una herencia no
si vinieron hace como 20 años nos
dejaron la herencia de la comida si está
bien lo que ocurre es que lo que éste
sobre dice es que la comida es apenas
una fracción de la verdadera herencia de
todos los peruanos la comida es apenas
la puntita del iceberg de la gran
herencia que es nuestra nuestra cultura
porque cuando se trata de cultura no
somos cualquier país somos un país
absolutamente único y especial y lo
sabemos se nos enseña en el colegio
desde niños se nos habla de la grandeza
del imperio incaico de las grandes
culturas anteriores a los incas pero de
alguna manera tenemos esa información
dormida estamos acostumbrados como
acostumbrados estábamos a tener los
platos de comida en nuestra mesa sin
haber descubierto sin haber despertado a
su verdadero valor
tuve una experiencia que a mí
personalmente me ayudó a notar cómo es
que nos hemos acostumbrado y no
valoramos nuestra cultura cuando tuve el
privilegio de trabajar en el ministerio
de cultura asistí a la instalación en
abril del 2017 al primer foro de
civilizaciones antiguas esto sucedió en
atenas en grecia y solamente
participaban los países que hemos sido
cunas de grandes civilizaciones para la
humanidad solamente los países más
importantes del globo en cultura
nuestros anfitriones los griegos nos
recibieron con su canciller la madre de
la cultura occidental estaba presente
también uno de los hombres más
influyentes del contexto internacional
actual el canciller de china
representando esa gran civilización
estaba el canciller de italia del
imperio romano estaba también el
canciller de irán representando a la
cultura persa el mismo canciller que
condujo la negociación del acuerdo
nuclear con el gobierno de los eeuu
estaba presente la india
estaba presente el imperio azteca méxico
estaba presente en perú
estando ahí a pesar de saberlo fue como
una epifanía
cuando se trata de cultura resulta que
somos una potencia mundial y no
terminamos de despertar ante esa noticia
así que
repitamos el ejercicio
también a nuestra mirada de nuestro
esquema mental miremos con una mirada
fresca y reconozcamos el valor de
nuestra cultura convirtamos la de verdad
y la embajadora del perú en el mundo
convirtamos la en un gran motivo de
peregrinación hacia el perú hagamos que
sea el corazón de nuestro orgullo
pero si nos tomamos un momento para
tratar de entender la magnitud de la
herencia qué significa nuestra cultura
podemos hacer algo más y si podemos
hacer algo más debemos hacerlo la
cultura además puede ser la llave del
desarrollo del perú
pensemos un instante que entendemos por
desarrollo nos hemos acostumbrado en las
últimas décadas a entender el desarrollo
como el crecimiento económico y el
crecimiento económico es fundamental
para el desarrollo pero solamente una
parte del desarrollo dejamos un ratito
descansar a la economía y vayamos un
instante a la biología qué quiere decir
desarrollo desarrollo quiere decir
alcanzar la plenitud de las
potencialidades que no son propias si
somos una semilla de manzana desarrollo
quiere decir que esa semilla permita que
se que germine un tallo que se convierta
en tronco que genere ramas y que
finalmente dé frutos y que frutos
queremos con el desarrollo de nuestra
semilla de lo que hacemos de lo que
somos queremos estar en capacidad de
enfrentar óptimamente nuestros desafíos
queremos convivir mejor entre los
peruanos queremos tener una sociedad
armoniosa estimulante creativa y por
supuesto también una sociedad
con prosperidad económica
hagamos el ejercicio miremos lo que
somos miremos nuestra semilla este
patrimonio que hemos heredado
por ejemplo como país el perú nosotros
tenemos una larga histórica rivalidad
con chile una rivalidad que me parece
que en los últimos años en los últimos
lustros se ha ido volviendo más sana y
que nos ayuda en muchos sentidos en este
momento en chile viven decenas de miles
de familias peruanas que son valoradas
en chile cuyo aporte a la sociedad
chilena es apreciado y nosotros sabemos
también apreciar a nuestros hermanos
chilenos reconocemos su gran capacidad
de organización su eficiencia imaginemos
por un instante que la ciudad la
ciudadela de caral si la más antigua de
américa aquí no más al norte de lima
cinco mil años de antigüedad imaginemos
que quedar en chile
podemos imaginar lo que harían los
chilenos si tuvieran canal lo que harían
los colombianos lo que harían los
ecuatorianos si tuvieran el privilegio
de contar en su tierra con esa ciudadela
nosotros estamos acostumbrados a tener
esta joya de la corona que es machu
picchu y todo lo que está en el cusco
ollantaytambo isaac estamos
acostumbrados pero si nos elevamos sobre
nuestro mapa y hacemos una especie de
vuelo virtual y vamos a entre las
fronteras de cusco con apurímac y vemos
choquequirao que no sé si conocen pero
que muchas de las personas que conocen
sienten y yo a veces me siento de
acuerdo con ellas que es hasta más
impresionante que machu picchu que es
esta ciudad de la increíble colocada en
lo alto de esta gran cuchilla que se
pierde en los cielos y si vamos a
ayacucho y vemos el sitio arqueológico
de huari de ese gran imperio anterior el
imperio incaico que en este momento
tenemos explorado apenas al 6% o bajamos
ahí acá tenemos las pampas de nasca y de
palpa esa especie de lienzo inexplicable
que hasta ahora asombra a la humanidad
hoy llegamos a lima y vamos a pachacamac
este otro gran santuario al borde del
desierto mirando el mar o nos vamos a
chavín de huántar patrimonio de la
humanidad o vamos más al norte
chan chan esa extraordinaria ciudadela
de barro que es la más grande de américa
la segunda más grande del mundo y que
también es patrimonio de la humanidad o
vamos a huaca rajada la casa del señor
de sipán ese señor que la national
geographic para que el mundo entienda
describió como el tutankamón de américa
nos vamos a esa bellísima fortaleza
elevada que escuela y para de contar
porque podría seguir todo esto es parte
de nuestro patrimonio todo esto debería
hacernos orgullosos y no estoy hablando
de quizá el aspecto más bello del
patrimonio cultural que es el patrimonio
inmaterial no estoy hablando de nuestras
danzas porque somos un país que baila en
todos sus rincones no estoy hablando de
nuestros gloriosos vestidos de nuestras
fiestas o de la festividad de la virgen
de la candelaria que mueve a decenas de
miles de personas en puno y que también
patrimonio de la humanidad o de la
peregrinación al santuario del señor del
color y tim el ausangate que también es
patrimonio de la humanidad y también
mueve decenas de miles de personas con
unos sentir orgullo por todo eso como no
compartir ese orgullo con todos nuestros
hermanos peruanos porque todos estamos
hermanados en esta herencia como no
convivir mejor al reconocer que esta
herencia la debemos a todos nuestros
rincones a todas nuestras lenguas a
todos nuestros acentos a todas nuestras
costumbres
y por supuesto como no imaginar el
extraordinario potencial económico que
significa este patrimonio el perú es
visitado fundamentalmente para conocer
este patrimonio la abrumadora mayoría de
turistas que vienen al país vienen por
nuestro patrimonio cultural
miremos un poquito el mundo españa el
2017 recibió 82 millones de turistas que
dejaron para españa 97 mil millones de
dólares estamos hablando de más o menos
la mitad del producto bruto interno del
perú méjico en el 2017 recibió poco más
de 39 millones de turistas que dejaron
21 mil millones de dólares para méxico
poco más del 10 por ciento de nuestro
pib y si españa quede en europa rodeada
de países con gente con muchos ingresos
es más fácil llegar méxico tiene
frontera con este gran gigante de la
economía que es estados unidos pero más
cerquita de nosotros colombia en el
norte chile en el sur el 2017 llevaron
6.5 millones de turistas son países
hermosos con mucho que ofrecer pero
teniendo lo que a vuelo de pájaro hemos
visto es posible que el perú el 2017
haya llevado apenas 3.8 millones un
poquito más de la mitad que chile y
colombia somos capaces de imaginar dónde
está el techo que tenemos para crecer
siendo además el turismo una industria
que genera muchísimo empleo y que podría
generarlo en todos los rincones de
nuestro país
reconozcamos volvamos a mirar el
potencial de nuestro patrimonio y si
somos una referencia mundial en comida
seamos una referencia mundial en turismo
y démonos cuenta de que el potencial de
nuestra cultura no termina en el turismo
pensemos por ejemplo los textiles
paracas los textiles nazca o los
textiles en los vestidos magníficos que
tenemos en todo el país porque no ser
una referencia mundial en moda pensemos
en nuestras artesanías en los exquisitos
retablos en nuestra orfebrería porque no
ser una referencia mundial en diseño en
joyería pensemos otra vez en una chupa
chups en chan chan en choque tirado
porque no atrevernos a hacer también una
referencia mundial en arquitectura
porque en los nuevos museos nuevas
bibliotecas públicas para todos los
peruanos que además sean hitos de la
arquitectura contemporánea y podemos
seguir
si hubiera que elegir un solo elemento
que defina a nuestro país ese elemento
sin ninguna duda es la cultura
hagamos el ejercicio
hagamos conciencia de lo que somos y del
valor de lo que tenemos
hagamos orgullo de nuestra cultura y
hagamos de ella el camino a nuestro
desarrollo el día que hagamos este
ejercicio y reconozcamos este valor y
nos transformemos a nosotros mismos y
nos demos cuenta de todo lo que somos
capaces desde nuestra cultura ese día
vamos a iniciar el camino para
convertirnos en la gran potencia que ya
somos en nuestra semilla hagamos que
nuestras niñas y niños sepan que nuestro
país se llama perú pero se apellida la
cultura
muchas gracias